the monks of semper temple kidnapped
hundreds of children all in the name of
immortality but what use is eternity if
you have to spend it with your sins
children give me that child she's the
only one responsible for their kidnap
were an order of SEM PO assassins deadly
and short in stature they would have
easily been able to sneak into homes and
steal people's young ones a leader among
them was black hat badger who is a
noteworthy character if for no other
reason then he has an animal tag
attached to his name among the SEM PO
assassins however his notable title was
that of black hat which was a
distinction that was given to the
wielder of the iron fortress a headpiece
that was passed down through generations
of assassins serving central temple
however in this era
it's especially common for allegiances
to change Lac hat is fighting like a
demon by the serpent Valley side of the
castle then that's where we're going
next but keep your wits about you the
black hat badger won't go down without a
fight
[Music]
told those morons to give it a rest but
they don't they just keep sending more
such a pain in my you one of them night
your cronies no no of course not there's
something different about you
but I'd say you're in the same line of
work the names black hat badger what's
yours
real sociable one aren't we first this
stubborn lot now it down in the dumps
shinobi could this day get any better
you're a fugitive something like that
your black hat is on the run pursued by
the best assassins of sin po temple but
also the nightjar personal assassins of
the iana elite these two factions have
experienced renewed relations under
Ganesha dome
since Ganesha Doe has a keen interest in
the monks experiments with the waters of
rejuvenation thinking I may be leaving
soon where to simple temple upon now
Kongo there's all sorts of rats around
here these days got a feeling things are
gonna get real ugly real soon so it's
about time I tied up some loose ends
take care of yourself here from the top
of our China castle to it's very depths
you'll find spies of the interior
ministry rats probing the country for
weaknesses but perhaps it's even more
common that you stumbled upon their
corpses cut up by the Tengu rats have
been swarming into ash in a castle these
days you know the one that I mean but
there's this hell-bent old timer cutting
them up like it was nothing
blackhat knows the Tengu is eachine as
he does reveal it to you later
before the end he has a grudging respect
for the mayor
who fights honestly for his country but
even with the tangos efforts the rats
keep swarming in the ministry is coming
and there's nothing anyone can do to
stop that the best you can do is tie up
loose ends and get out while you still
can
well well if it isn't all chuckles did
you take care of your business that I
did all thanks to you
whose grave is this this it's a he
belongs to my kid
I see after the little run passed away
all the grunt work I used to do just
didn't cut it
experiments with rejuvenation kidnapping
responsibilities of a black hat
everything to do with this temple was
just rubbing me the wrong way so that's
why you quit yeah that's right well that
takes care of my business here I owe you
one
oh by the way you probably figured
already but us you know you know she
reeks of charred corpses and gunpowder
something fierce
the rats are flooding in like you
wouldn't believe mm-hmm you watch
yourself out there when it finally came
time to set fire to wash in his walls
the interior ministry was ready the one
weakness of a Sheena's red-eyed monsters
which the interior ministry fear is fire
and so the ministry designed weapons
that specifically exploit that weakness
additionally a special dousing powder
was created something that would prevent
the ministry's own soldiers from
succumbing to burns as a final insult
among their forces to appear to be sent
PO assassins garbed in red now betrayers
of sinpo just as they were betrayers of
blackhat
badger look who it is
I couldn't take it too many rats
swarming in out of the woodwork
he must have terrified him that's why I
gone and done something a little out of
character what happened there wasn't any
rats they were closing in on a little
kid so so I saved him
and now look at me guess the great black
hat bad your story ends here I gotta
thank you take what you want when I'm
gone I would give it to you now
it's amoeba balloon made in the year of
the dragon spring pilgrimage and sealed
with a prayer for a healthy upbringing
on it is written to 10kg from badger a
gift to his son that he just wanted to
hold on to a little bit longer
hopefully the act of sacrificing himself
to save a small child in some small way
righted his bad come if you watch this
video the week that it came out then the
next episode is actually already out and
you can watch it right now it's just
over on patreon I have a bunch of reward
tiers over there but I think that giving
early access is probably my favorite one
because it allows me to sort of demo my
videos to a small dedicated audience and
then also reward those people for
helping to keep the channel going so if
you love from Software's games go and
check it out but of course whether
you're a patron or not you'll get to see
the video very soon and thank you for
watching